اقتحمت قوات اسرائيليه مدينتي نابلس
والبيره وبلده عاره في الضفه الغربيه وقد
حاصرت قوات الاحتلال منزلا في حي الشرفه
وسط مدينه البيره فور اقتحامها المدينه
بينما شهدت دوريات تابعه لجيش الاحتلال
تقتحم بلده عاره كما اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
مدينه نابلس شماليه الضفه الغربيه ودهمت
عددا من المنازل في الجبل الشمالي واعتقلت
شابين
فلسطينيين
وقد اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال شقيقتي الشهيد
صالح العاروري نائب رئيس المكتب السياسي
لحركه حماس الذي اغتيل في العاصمه
اللبنانيه بيروت مطلع الشهر الجاري وقال
مراسل الجزيره ان قوات الاحتلال دهمت منزل
عائله العاروري في بلده عاروري رام الله
واعتقلت دلال العاروري ام قتيبه بينما
اعتقلت فاطمه العاروري خلال اقتحام مدينه
البيره في الضفه
الغربيه